[Música]
la mina de oro de Pueblo Viejo en el
corazón de República Dominicana es una
de las más grandes del mundo la empresa
canadiense Barry Gold extrae aquí más de
15 toneladas de oro al año León cerramos
es agricultora creció en este Valle
antes de la mina de la Barry Gold llegar
aquí nosotros vivíamos felices Nosotros
vivíamos bien nosotros éramos
millonarios millonario en todo que hoy
nos falta Todo 50 años de explotación
Industrial han convertido la remota
localidad de Cotuí en una inmensa mina a
cielo abierto hoy el yacimiento de
pueblo viejo se está agotando
para mantener el ritmo Barry Gold ha
obtenido nuevas concesiones este paisaje
desolado pronto se extenderá por todo el
valle nosotros lo único que tenemos aquí
en muchas enfermedades muchos problemas
la maldición más grande de nosotros fue
nacer donde estaba el oro
el proceso de extracción utiliza cianuro
para separar el oro de sus impurezas y
los lodos contaminados se almacenan en
esta cuenca de retención
afirma que su gestión de residuos es
respetuosa con el medio ambiente pero
los residentes locales no están de
acuerdo León cerramos siempre ha vivido
en Cotuí ha visto cómo cambiaban los
ríos a causa de la mina esa espuma es de
lo que han bajado el agua y de eso de
los tóxicos pero el río estaba bastante
sucio ya es un cadáver pero no porque ya
da el servicio que tenía que dar antes a
las comunidades
la contaminación no es la única amenaza
para el valle comadre
Ven por aquí
casi el talima vive justo enfrente de la
presa que retiene el lodo tóxico de la
mina esta madre vive con el temor
constante de que La Represa se rompa
Qué te parece si viene un ciclón o una
vaguada a la cabecera de nosotros es el
muro de la presa de cola entonces Esas
son de una de las cosas que más me
preocupan porque yo le decía yo creo en
lo que hace dios Yo no creo en lo que
hace el hombre
hace dos meses Casilda Lima pensó que
sus temores estaban haciendo realidad
justamente donde va que el camión allá
pasando ahí fue que
comenzó
ese elemento de material
decidió grabar la escena y compartir el
video
por ese video
ha sido como quien dice chantajeada al
parecer le pidió a Casilda Lima que
viniera a ver el estado de La Represa un
equipo de la empresa le pidió entonces
que publicara un video para tranquilizar
a los habitantes del Valle Casilda Lima
se niega a desmentir su video original
le hace un daño si yo de miento el video
estoy defraudando mi familia estoy
defraudando mi vecino estoy defraudando
mi comunidad y Esas son una cosa que una
vez se me llena de impotencia me da
tristeza Alguna vez se me dan hasta
deseo de llorar
no respondió a nuestra solicitudes de
entrevista
León cerramos fundó el comité nuevo
Renacer con vecinos de la mina
juntos denuncian los abusos de la
industria minera
saludo cómo están Buenas tardes buenas
tardes bienvenido bien adelante
tras años de lucha el comité se ha
resignado a lo Inevitable los 450
habitantes del Valle han aceptado
abandonar sus tierras natales el
gobierno debería reubicarlos en los
próximos meses a unos 100 kilómetros al
norte de Cotuí para nosotros va a ser un
sacrificio y algo muy doloroso entender
que abandonar nuestra tierra lo que
tanto sacrificio no ha tocado pero la
comisión no tiene intención de detener
la lucha sus miembros quieren evitar que
otras regiones corran la misma suerte
Ojalá nosotros que toda esa provincia
nos hiciera no una sola y lucháramos en
contra de la explotación minera Aunque
la minería es que trae el dinero pero
también va a traer acabar con la
humanidad Si siguen de esa forma
en el Noroeste del país
otra empresa canadiense inició en 2020
la prospección de nuevos yacimientos de
oro
obtuvo su licencia minera en febrero del
año pasado
máximo Guzmán responsable de una
asociación ecologista ya está viendo la
huella de la empresa
vamos por la trocha esto es una trocha
que hace la compañía minera unigol para
la exploración máximo Guzmán está
preocupado por el impacto de la
industria minera en el medio ambiente
preservado de su región
hemos visto en otro pueblo como Cotuí lo
que ha pasado Entonces nosotros no vamos
a permitir eso pero en esta zona
fronteriza con Haití donde el 80% de la
población vive por debajo del umbral de
pobreza Los argumentos de Máximo Guzmán
no tienen Mucho peso frente a las
promesas de desarrollo económico en 2021
el oro aportó a República Dominicana más
de 1500 millones de euros
[Música]